je pense qu'il faut savoir éviter une
magnifique histoire de l'architecturé
quand on hérite et une part que l'on
girl il ya une partie on rejette
je suis un grand héritier d'aimé des
modernes comme comme redire à l'évidence
il ya une part des modernes que je ne
peux pas du tout accepté si ça du projet
génériques et c'est celle qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le monde des bâtisseurs
est responsable depuis de 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui il est absolument
nécessaire de changer notre posture face
à la fabrication des établissements
humains et si je dois le dire en une
phrase je pense que si le 19e siècle a
été révolutionnée en ce qui concerne le
bâtiment par l'acier si le 20e siècle a
effectivement révolutionné
l'architecturé grâce au béton 21e siècle
sera grâce aux matériaux biosourcés
[Musique]